there's a story that says you bought an
inversion table so that you could make
yourself a quarter of an inch taller so
that you could get an extra 10 pounds
weight limit in your category is this
true I tried yeah I did it came with a
100 page pamphlet and like 500
instructions to put it together and I
never put it together I went to a
chiropractor consistently they have a
machine
it's got no machine that just pulls you
is that not just the medieval rack is
that not a torture thing that looks like
you've got a peasant with one of those
floppy caps on it like this we'll get
you one installer literally yeah it
looks more like Frankenstein you like
sit in this machine like upright and
then it tilts you down they have a thing
around your waist that just pulls your
spine and I did that for a while I'm
just over a six one so I'd have to agree
in a full inch to be over six two so I'm
like I would never do it but I also
don't want to shrink I've definitely
tried a few things I hang from bars all
the time too elongate my spine it's also
just good for your spine but yes classic
physique is just a battle to be taller
essentially to make your weight